it's like the new order actually
probably the best game in the
Wolfenstein series you might say I was a
bit of a shock last year oh you wanted
you want Andy Barron right off the bat
you want to destroy your counterpoint I
love all the Wolfenstein is equally you
know so graduation no that's not I
didn't love the 2009 one No Return to
Castle design no it's just called
Wolfenstein well we'll just no Nazi
magic comes dogs a crock oh man that one
had some good good sniper rifle action
though alright that's about it way to
find the positive alley yeah good well
in any case we can all agree that you're
one awesome we go get yeah I loved it we
still good very surprising very
emotional right okay can we talk about
that anything really no no no mostly
because I have an affinity okay I'm
noting that finishing it at the moment
on xbox big like you know character did
that line between absurd but actually
like making me feel something Dale and
it's so brilliantly done that was like
laughing but like it's the dumbest thing
I think like absurd is all hell 60g
Boscovich you know like one of the most
one-dimensional characters in the
history of video game yeah literally a
face to the bottom and then like yes and
then he's just a like not snotty hunting
crazy person yep even in the new order
but he's also like incredibly brilliant
cipa that again but like all day and all
the people who talk to more like you're
crazy just gonna kill ya so great
character we're all like really excited
to hear that the announcement of
stand-alone dlc coming out the old blood
is out today it's there's like is there
another wanders this just a two-part
pack yeah so this one contains two like
swords yes stories within it and so the
first one is go back to Castle
Wolfenstein try to steal ducks well it
all began yeah but this is in 1946 so
its like before the alternate is like
it's just the beginning of the alternate
history that defines the new order
because that takes place in the 60s
right after the Nazis one so this one
it's like 1946 yeah or should have been
over by now but it's not and the Nazis
are really winning right kind of
and you guys have played and even
playing on PC Chris you've been playing
on xbox one yes Andy first of all what
are your first impressions of the old
blood all right so it starts out pretty
slow yes you're in a car and then it
goes to a part where you're in a prison
and it's very linear and they're like
have these little stealth battles with
these super soldiers that are attached
by heathers okay like power station says
it feels like a trolley car something in
a streetcar that was like attached to
the power grid liver yeah and so they
can always go back and forth anyway from
the lego thing you like power down and
then it's like but then you might like
certain amount of time to go like
disconnect them oh cool yeah so it's
like means you know start that's to me
that's not what this game is good at
yeah it's the stout stuff was always
part of it but it doesn't even like most
is like a force stealth auto this isn't
even like optional stealthy okay but
then you get past that and it's kind of
like mood building and stuff but then it
just drops you into an arena classic
willful sin double guns egg double guns
you know kill the commander if you don't
want to set off the alarm but like of
course you do want to set up it's fun
and all the mobility stuff is there and
it's brilliant let's go fun right yeah I
mean why wouldn't you want to pay if you
get if you can play the first one this
is only twenty bucks yeah its standalone
so if you wanna go to say so what this
games all about Ty Lee recommend just
jumping in here getting through that
first part and then you like using all
your means your slides your power slides
your guns or dual guns like it's just
there's so many options the shooting is
so good I don't even know what yeah once
you get past that stealth stuff well
there's like a little dig give you a
little taste before you get his cell
stuff but I'm still in the cell stuff
the xbox one download took significantly
longer then still have the only like
okay we got really fast super fast
internet here yeah so there's no but you
know no backlog on our end but steam had
it and like I get it yeah it took me
like two hours in just two hours oh yeah
but yeah so like this this is where
things start to get Judy in this brief
sequence the the shooting mechanics in
this game and the movement stuff I just
like really combines to make it so fun
and that's that's Andy's enthusiasm that
you guys are feeling I like it because
as is I like as a standalone sort of
dlc thing it's a prequel so it's not
there's not gonna be spoilers or
anything there's not going to be
knowledge that you're assumed to have
known but they but at same time you are
seeing like the super soldiers you see
tethered up like you fight those dudes
free roaming like late in the new order
yes but you see that this is like the
progression that's what they meant at
the batteries and like the Robo dog that
you see is more dog than robot this one
but then in the new order it's just like
real gnarly robot mostly also the Nazis
blow up real good it's important double
barrel yeah heads explode pretty well
and like uh the one thing about this
game though is the guns don't have a
really meaty sound mmm they don't have a
real op they're just like yeah which is
weird cuz everything else is so like
spot-on you feel like it maybe it's your
headphones or something I don't know I
feel like I remember maybe there's
anywhere that you order kind of happened
don't you send these my last question
about this for keep really cool info for
people who haven't displayed and the new
order and you're suggesting people can
go in and jump in on this one and Chris
do you think that this does a good job
of explaining the mechanics to people at
the start or do you cannot believe it oh
no no there's no you know the in this
case you know knowing that you can slide
in your slide has momentum and like
actually they do they to you yeah
because you used tick a pipe under the
door and it's like okay to get under
there you have to run back oh I don't
show that to you in the first hour game
oh really like that's a while in but
then again that's you know that was
really wanted to combat arenas start
blossoming and opening up they give you
the guns pretty quickly and they got you
let you do wield real quickly but I
guess he'll look yeah the full stealth
it like block at the beginning doesn't
feel that strong to me but and yeah in
terms of I was just say read the
tutorials like an tutorial message pops
up they do a good job of like they have
a couple different ways of doing it once
it's like there's a tutorial message and
others like here's an image of the thing
that you're doing this is how you do it
and it goes away pretty quickly it's
kind of a slick interface but just pay
attention to that stuff if you haven't
played it before and you should be
getting up to speed and don't start on
uber difficulty if you're sure like
start a little lower and then if it's
feeling easy pick it up alright it's a
it's a first person shooter so it's like
people will instantly be here but the
only things that I think that it has it
people may be starved of it I wish every
shooter had these bunny lene mechanics
like you can lead you can even like lean
up down lean back yeah that all type
direction of lean is cool it has kind of
like an auto lean when you aim down
sights and you're in cover kind of like
does it so yeah you know it's forgiving
like far cry style yeah it has the
sliding which is just I love the sliding
I don't know and then the level design
actually is pretty key because there's
things you can like knock down and then
like go up yep get elevation that you
might not notice if you're not pay
attention there's like wait vents you
can climb into kind of like go around
and flank so there's like the levels all
kind of function this way even in the
battle arenas there's plenty of stuff to
to like hide reload maybe you notice
something oh I can jump up there go flag
so the other way you can like try again
that's it's just really well designed
like we know how to make a fun game
excellent i'm hopefully they know how to
make a good fall out cuz i saw nuka-cola
is already in this game this is machine
games oh yeah kapoor else this is the
speed and yeah there was also a Skyrim
the helmet sitting all the risks right
and bright early onset 01 universe they
love their little bit but does universe
as twitch word it says diverse they go
it's like it's like em red faction and
saints row it's all just one big
University I mean Chris thank very much
coming on talking about Wolfie times you
go pay some more yeah
you